okay
for people joining this live stream we
are doing a design review of some
new language features for language and
after a little bit of a gap
i'm back here in my day job which i like
very much
um making forward progress i hope
with wolfram language so we've got a
variety of topics here this is one i
didn't necessarily expect to see
solar time um right
so jeff yeah good you know talking of
solar time whatever happened to things
like
next new moon we were just discussing
that and at the end
the last subsection here is about that
so the proposal here is that motivated
by the
works on astronomical calendars and
astral work in general
we would like to have a parallel
function to sidereal time which is solar
time
okay so let me understand what we've got
right now
we have a sidereal time function right
now yes
i don't even know that okay so this is
an angle
so this notation is a notation for
angles
so 24 hours of right ascension is uh
so we're right now at about e radians
right um yes so sidereal time reports
the angle of rotations with respect to
stars
and solar time will report the angle of
rotation with respect to the sun
because the earth is moving around the
sun the two angles are diff
are changing by four minutes each day
so yeah so with this will be in the same
units that's the thing we
have to discuss in the next section it's
not obvious what to use
as outward because the tradition is to
use
um angles for sidereal time but not for
solar
yeah so these are mixed units of angle
it's essentially the right right
ascension uh
coordinate line that is on your local
meridian right now
so it's an angle
okay so are you proposing perhaps to use
a time object
for the um for solar time as if if it's
as as if it's a time zone
yeah so i think the two main
possibilities is either a time object or
a quantity time in mixed
units too these times of two hours
minutes seconds
so that's the discussion the next
subsection
and um
if this is 12 there is this prototype in
the solar
in the planetary astronomy functionality
okay but
so it doesn't matter but for example
that example shows
the use of this so the difference
between the the solar time
and the time object reports for example
how far you
are from your correct time zone which
for champagne we are moved one hour
because of daylight saving but other
than that we are almost perfect
okay so okay so what's the question here
so you're saying
the output type i do think having time
object each these things
will be good
right
um so you're saying
it might just be hours minutes seconds
mixed magnitude
basically relative to midnight exactly
okay let's see if their use and like the
equation of time
um
what's mean doing there oh i see
yes it's just to have the zero there the
middle
okay right
so that's that works well because the
subtraction of two time objects
are quantities if this was already a
quantity we wouldn't i mean
what would we have to do we would have
to convert the dates into a quantity
so wait a minute so this is
i'm now confused so the time object
if if the solar time here was this
quantity object
are you saying this would work or not
work
did you understand what i'm asking yes
yes yes
i think we would have to extract a time
object
from the date object and then convert
that into a quantity
because converting the date object
directly into a quantity
it's not that easy so so the this actual
computation
probably prefers time objects to
quantities
and it doesn't yet work to say time
object of sidereal time is that correct
no but i think it should
and that would simply be okay so the
real question is
is solar time i mean you know our
various time objects like unix
time is in some totally different bazaar
units
right yes and even local time
is a data object so so we have a variety
of outputs
why isn't local time a time object
specifically local times primary purpose
is looking at local time for a location
and we wanted to have the data part of
it because
local date was kind of weird but yeah
but
solar date solar time being a date
object would be weird
by the way if i say time object of this
okay yep we extract the time part
what the heck is that doing
no date objects and and time objects are
different things
i i have to admit i i've rarely found
standalone time
objects to be useful usually if you're
going to do anything useful with them
you have to instantiate them to some
particular day in order to do additional
things but
my use case is very limited so
well what about the possibility that in
this case that solar time returns a
quantity object
and that for this computation if this
was also a date object
right then this would just
well no it wouldn't work yeah it would
work if if
if what happened is no it wouldn't work
so if solar time was a date object then
that would work
immediately so data object minus states
which are data objects sorry if solar
time was what
a date object yeah but what date would
it give what what what term you know
what day of what day of the year
it today or at least the same one
that you give in the second argument
it's just like a modification
i see i see so solar time
would be the analog of local time but in
the you know
in solar time is what the romans would
have given for local time so to speak
exactly exactly that's not stupid
um by the way is a question from our
live stream from ben
asking is this stuff computed locally i
assume that it is
yes it is okay yes
we have all the information the orbital
information needed
and this also relies on on tables of
the continuous version of lip seconds
which are there
i see okay do we need different concepts
for apparent solar time and mean solar
time
i saw both concepts coming up when i was
trying to read up about this stuff
so these reports apart in solar time
which is inherent
okay yes the mean solar time
is what i that's why i use that
essentially
uh means all our time is this thing that
is
utc plus minus 0.9 seconds at most
so why aren't we allowing a time zone
arrow local mean time
which is the solar time
windage object yes we could do that it
would be local apart in time so local
mean time
is the one that follows this thing
called the minsan
which moves at homogeneous speed while
the true sun
moves faster or slower depending on how
far we are from it because of the
orbital eccentricity so hold on so what
are you saying here so you're saying
okay when back in the day right if
if you look up at data more from alpha
from a long time ago it will use local
mean time
before time zones exist yeah and our
name time zone database does that so if
you say
the time zone offset for america chicago
in 1800 it will give a
local mean offset how do i find that out
if i say time zone
if you say time zone offset yeah
and if you say america slash chicago as
a
yeah or any of
time zones there and then the second
argument has to be zero because that's
the time zone you're referring to
and then if you give a date that is like
1800
it was before the railways were built
okay
yeah and so the the time zone offset
database that we use
from uh the
the calendar system we have basically
tracks anytime before you have an
official declaration
statutory in terms of when time zones
go in we basically fall back to local
mean solar time
for the reference location because all
of the
time zones are out so could i request a
time zone of local mean solar time
or can i not do that for for the can't
do it right now because we basically
have to just infer that it's always
going to be
your current geolocation
um because if we if we're looking at
local mean solar time or local apparent
solar time we need a location which
isn't
currently a parameter in date objects at
all
we could just say you know the local
time will always be relative to whatever
we assume your location is
based on dollar geo position or dollar
but we could also have i mean we've got
a geo location
option right
um we could perfectly well have a
geolocation option
for these things which would also
presumably i mean we could say time zone
arrow whatever
you know or we could say geolocation
whatever and that could default to the
correct time zone for that geolocation
you mean data object would take geo
location as an option
that's what i'm suggesting yeah
we've talked about potentially having if
you say time zone goes to a location
it could either mean i want to look up
what the time zone of this location is
currently or i want to use some local
solar time approximation and so
i don't think we should do that secondly
i think you should explicitly ask for
local solar time
because it's a it's a weird case right
yeah okay yeah i mean i think you know
functionality wise it's not hard to do
it's just thinking of
do we want to have those two
interdependent options
or because location is potentially a
parameter and other things with dates
that have to do with with astronomical
calendars
but that's maybe a bit of a tangent for
us to
well wait wait wait wait wait wait
oh oh you mean if you feed in one of
those data objects that has a geo
location
those functions would have to know how
to extract that geolocation from the
option instead of requiring a separate
geolocation
argument is that what you mean nick
that wasn't specifically what i was
thinking of i was thinking of some of
the work we're doing with
with expanding the calendars framework
to account for astronomical calendars
that
need a reference location to figure out
calendar conversions which is a
different use of a location
what's an example of one of those uh so
um like the astronomical persian
calendar
for example is typically your reference
locations typically tehran
for doing all of your astronomical
calculations but you in principle could
use
any given location within iran or
somewhere else and use the same calendar
is that a currently in use calendar
system
uh i don't believe the persian one is
currently used but it's not
super far out of date and there are
other
uh so some of the islamic calendars are
astronomical
and are currently in use and so they
follow the
yeah sorry yes i was going to say that
the issue there is that these calendars
start the day at sunset or or sunrise
so in order to know the the time of
sunset or sunrise you need to know what
you are
but i think that that's a that's a
separate detail from what we are
discussing here
so well but you're saying that the date
in in the i mean
it's not using january 1st it's using a
different month system
right isn't that correct for those
calendars
yes yes because they will be using yeah
yeah so these calendars are following
the moon or whatever
right but and then they require a
geolocation to say what you mean by
that particular day month day
combination correct yep so we're going
to have to have a geolocation and date
object
at some point anyway that's what you're
telling me
so what we're saying is you know there
are calendars that follow the moon et
cetera et cetera or we can also have
the now i believe globally out of date
calendar of local means sold mean solar
time
which would have to have a geolocation
yeah sorry sorry i
i think there are two different things
here one
is the fact that you need to know at
your location in order to to
know this exact number that you have
there which is essentially your
longitude
the other thing is that there is these
two concepts of apparent
time and mean time so meantime
is a recently introduced concept in the
18th century
when they realized that the sun was
moving through the skies at different
speeds
so they invented a concept called the
mean sun
and the mean sun moves at constant speed
so this didn't exist like in the
fourteen hundreds
even though i don't understand i'm sorry
to ask a naive question
it moves at different apparent speeds
because the earth is at different
distances from the sun is that correct
it's a combination of two things that's
one the other thing is the tilting
as the this as this earth
moves around the sun the tilting is
varying with respect to the say the
orientation to the sun
and that's that combination of two
effects is precisely the equation of
time
that's why the equation of time has this
div this weird shape
it's the superposition of two
sinusoidals which are not aligned
so one of them is is the is the 23
degree
tilt of the earth and one of them is the
eccentricity of the earth's orbit
exactly and so
those two things if you average them
then you get mean sun
and the a mean sign would be a
horizontal line in that equation of time
okay by the way the the the orbit of the
earth around the sun
i mean it preserves the rangi lens
vector to a high degree of accuracy yes
i mean it's
it's the ellipse is not processing to
any significant extent is that true
the ellipse is not processing
perihelion it's not like mercury where
there's a
you know substantial advance of the
perihelion
well everything that can change in
astronomy will be changing
so to some degree it does change but it
it's
it's a very small degree and in fact on
long terms the eccentricity earth does
change
um that's a lot of the uh ice ages
things like that they talk about um
trying to remember what the name of the
procession of the equinoxes but that's a
different effect no not procession
that's uh the actual eccentricity does
change and so does the tilt of the earth
over long periods
um and those two together tilt is the
procession of the equinoxes isn't it
yes yes so stephen stephen is talking
about whether the ecliptic
processes i need that right a little bit
but it does
yeah okay okay so
okay so let's go back here all right
let's
unwind this okay first point solar time
i think we're concluding it should be
a um uh a data object
with an effective time zone
right
yeah and we need it we need to name it i
mean we should probably put some kind of
thing here that says you know solar time
or something
why is there a period in that gmt minus
five it shouldn't have a period there
minor point but it should get fixed yeah
well
because sometimes zones are found 4.5
i am well aware but if it's not if it's
not 4.5
let's not have it be a have a period
there okay okay
um okay what are we going to
call this if this is is there a standard
abbreviation for solar time that we can
put in here
or we could just say solar there
to indicate that it's solar time
well i think the important work here is
local even though
local time is it's not it's not exactly
that
i think we should call it solar because
i think it's what i mean otherwise
people will be just irreducibly confused
um okay if it returns a date object
solar time returns a date object
then the equation of time is easy to
compute
it's just the difference between a date
object
and for a particular location
fine okay now um
this business about the mean sun versus
the apparent sun
how are we dealing with that
are you saying that solar time which
which of those does solar time use
solar time is the true sun
and then our civil time follows the
minsan
what what is civil time what what's is
that the thing we're proposing with a
with a new time zone
no no the the the sun the time that we
get from
from now or date object so the the
time of the computer is is
effectively mean solar time plus minus
one
0.9 seconds wait a minute this
particular thing here
this is based on some you know
generalized atomic clock somewhere this
has nothing to do with the location of
the sun
well it was synchronized long ago
to be that so that that
that m there means it's the mean time
is greenwich mean time minus four hours
and greenwich mean time is the one that
is now
uh following the titanic okay
i understand so the mean and greenwich
mean time is because it is following the
mean sun
yes that's that's how they first
introduced it
then they realized that looking at
sidereal time was more precise because
the equivalent of the equation of time
rather than moving 60 minutes moves one
second
at most why does it move one second
because the you don't have to worry
it's all it's mutation it's it's the
effect of mutation
okay yeah um and so you can also average
it
and you get me inside your real time
so how do we get in from our system how
do we get me inside aerial time
or is that what sidereal time is giving
no cedilla time is given
the the the apparent criteria time the
truth
do we say that no but i just i mean if
you go to the
to the page to the author page i just
added a tentative note
okay all right fine i believe you right
okay so
so then how would we get mean sidereal
time
mean side aerial time is a time zone
like solar time
right so the two main times are
effectively the same
modulo uh a proportionality factor
and uh yes
so look what i would propose is that we
have two things here
we have um
local mean solar time local means
sidereal time
i don't know what what are our time
zones typically it's um
we probably don't need to say uh time
here
so we have those two each of them has
sidereal
um each of them has at least for local
means solo
both of them need a geo location don't
they but
i i think this is not correct so mean
has nothing to do with time zones so
what we need here is to say something
like
you need to look at your longitude so
here the word is something like
local longitude we could say longitude
local longitude
um location
i'm sorry for for which for the time
zone for a time zone to say
use the time zone that would be derived
from your location
independently of which type of time you
are working with
right so so i see so you but isn't this
cool
when you see lmt local mean time
yes that corresponds to the
to this what is that
so in general when you use when you see
the word local
in in these astronomy functions it means
you are using your longitude rather than
the longitude that
the average longitude of your time zone
okay i mean time zone when we say time
from chicago
we are effectively using the the yeah
some average value
here but
hmm so i mean you're saying you're
saying this is really
this or alternatively we could as well
say
time zone i see you i see i see
i see so if you do here bracket
longitude in quotes divided by 24
that's the number we are looking for
here here
other brackets from good youth and now
divide by 24.
that's the number we want to insert
there
so if we said timezone are a local
longitude
would that be clear yes i think that
would be very clear
okay and then we don't have to
distinguish sidereal and solar is that
correct
exactly yes okay and then if
if you say time zone to local longitude
then
then that would you would be able to
give a remote geolocation rather than
using the here geolocation
right and we would take the longitude of
that
location okay but if you said time zone
arrow at geo position
what is it going to do then then that is
doing
the same thing that time zone
um that this time zone offset presumably
does if i give time zone offset
a geo position it presumably computes
like local time does it presumably
completes the local time
i think it does not do that
yeah go ahead yeah currently it takes
the position and it
looks up what the time zone associated
with that is so if you say
that's that's what i would expect that's
exactly what i would expect
so in other words we could get back to
if we said local time
of local time of time zone arrow local
longitude
would return what solar time
sidereal time which one
time yeah yeah
and why and what about the offset to get
to sidereal time
in other words should there be a time
zone that corresponds to sidereal time
no but sidereal time
is 23 hours and whatever it is seconds
you know exactly yes so the difference
between solar time and saturated time is
this proportionality factor
i understand i mean so you're saying the
days don't align inside aerial time the
day is only a line in solar time
exactly it's ideal time it's it's um
exactly that's why people typically do
not
refer to a full date object
in the sidereal time cases yes right
because it doesn't make any sense
okay fine all right i think we have a
plan here
so um go ahead
the thing missing is the mean versus
apparent and perhaps
we could just have a method option that
says by default is apparent
and method goes to mean time for which
case now is this
both sided time and solar time
and so for for solar time
of method goes to mean time would give
essentially the same thing that that now
gives
plus minus 0.9 seconds
so does this make any sense
no no no time zone is only about your
position not about which time you are
using
sorry remind me again the apparent time
versus the mean time
what's the difference yeah so the
imagine the definition of noon noon is
when the sun crosses
your local horizon right the the the
your local meridian sorry
the the yeah the highest point in your
sky
now this the sun is moving at varying
speed the mean sun is something that
moves at constant speed
so they may cross that line slightly
different
times okay
and that's why you have this this
equation of time precisely mentioned
that difference across the year
but you're saying that the thing that
people when they say solar time they
mean apparent solar time because if it
was mean they would just use ordinary
time
exactly yes okay
so i mean i don't think we should have a
method option i mean if you say solar
time you want
the apparent solar time not the mean
time which you could as well get by just
using the ordinary data object
right so the only difference is this my
plus minus 0.9 seconds
why does longitude not work for here
why does that not work by default i
think it should i
don't know good yeah um
yeah anyway simple thing and also
question why
would does this make sense to give
a meridian is that silly what is it what
would it give
we have your path of meridian of some
longitude
as a primitive interior
of most list string meridian
and now give some located
okay and then if i say geo graphics
of that
okay yeah and we have
we have named things like tropic of
cancer
i see that will always be vertical and
not on that projection
yes i think you can say actually from
this
latitude to that latitude in another
argument
okay but if i just take some other
random projection
what is that obvious
it's being centered dude your range goes
to all
it's because it's centering at that
without the e mole by
okay i'm confused these all happen to
have it be vertical
because the map is being centered at the
only thing you gave
so do geo range goes to all or world
which
chooses the fixed minus hundred to
so the arrange goes to all or world we
choose
there i see okay
okay okay all right okay so wait a
minute where were we at so are we are we
resolved to all the issues that we
needed to resolve or not
uh i think so i i think the introducing
the mean
functions perhaps we can do i mean
the mean method option we can do that
when we introduce
lip seconds everywhere because then it
will be easier to understand what it
means
yes what is this variation of one second
i don't understand the variation of one
second thing that points seconds
yes so the the same thing you see there
for solar time which varies 15 minutes
up
and up above and below but the same
thing happens for sidereal time
it's called the equation of equinoxes
and that is because of mutation in the
in the rotation of the earth
exactly that's complicated it's amazing
people figured all this stuff out
um yes yes and this is all creates these
problems that
you are saying i'm looking at this
object in the sky which is moving and
it's moving with respect to a coordinate
system which is also moving
so you have to give two times when you
give
coordinates the time at which you are
measuring at the time
defining the reference system with
respect to which you are measuring
right okay this particular thing here we
need
we had that in fact in the in the low
hanging fruit
notebook we had a list of next
things like next new moon and things
right but the discussion here is what's
the general design of this because
next is very unstable we have this
problem with eclipses you say what's the
next eclipse
and then you ask a property of the
eclipse and it jumps again
so i think i think we we fixed this
right jeff recently
so that it doesn't fit uh correct yes we
fixed that some time back
so what is the issue because you now
want some properties so you say solar
eclipse of percent comma
i don't know totally past or something
like that
and it would jump and give you the next
eclipse because it was always defined to
give you the next
right that's stupid yeah and so we've
basically addressed that so that it now
treats it like it's
entity like essentially
yeah okay path of totality i don't know
what's the name for this property
um whatever the name is the
autocompleter is not working
oh yes it is um
total phase polygon
oh i've messed up that
okay cool okay
right so so the general question here is
how do you find some events in these
oscillating functions
and so this looks very much like a find
root computation
okay so explain that so so you're saying
so i'm saying that rather than basing
things in the next
concept it should probably be based on
find the event within these limits
because i know that this only happens
every month so i give you a month
it's like find the scissors of some
astronomical system
exactly within this range exactly
or find the closest approach
the perihelion or something exactly
and because it's it repeats you need to
specify in which period you want it
how does that relate to our repeating
events in the date
framework like in other words if i want
to know
you know when are the uh you know give
me
all the you know i don't know jewish
holidays within this range or something
is that a related thing and how is that
how do we specify that
so that's a function nick is working on
called
date select which you would give a
range a list of dates or a range of
dates via an interval and then you
specify the criteria
and the criteria are ex they're
basically the elements available
in date value where there's some there
are properties of any given
date or instance that we could look up
um
but so do you have to be able to solve
something there i mean is it the same
type of issue because i mean
essentially what's happening here is you
say the phase of the moon
you know it's almost like moon phase
equals equals 0.92 or something
[Music]
i mean essentially what you're saying is
you know what you want is
a date find or something except it might
be date select
date interval blah blah blah
comma moon phase
well this is really weird i mean moon
phase
of hash equals equals 0.92
that type of thing
right these continuous cases look
different and would require an internal
framework that is
quite different but that's what you're
saying i mean so
so you say finding the perihelion or
something
well see because like moon phase equals
0.92 is a distinct moment
as is the perihelion
right an eclipse for example is not a
distinct moment
okay so you're proposing a find astro
event
yes for the moment yes i'm not super
sure
but yes i think we need something
specific
for the for the continuous solving case
rather than the look at the properties
of date value
and extract yeah
um
what are you saying sorry the the yes i
i have the impression that the the
discrete cases and continuous cases here
work separately
well are you suggesting that we have a
fine astronomical event
and i mean we might have some special
cases for next i i think we need a next
full moon and all that kind of stuff
next moon full and so on and so on and
so on
this might be a special i think that's a
special case yeah i mean we the earth
has one moon we all live all right
you know let's let's you know uh let's
let's support the moon especially
right um
but i think the general case of find
astronomical event and then perihelions
and things
is worthwhile
right because we can we can create the
powerful language in the first argument
for specifying properties
and then yes then the second argument
just gives you the range you are
interested in
um so we have a bunch of comments on our
live stream that i want to address let's
address them from the end ethan is
complaining about
our uh map backgrounds and their
pixelation we are working on that
um um in terms of the labeling it's
pretty ugly
i agree and the coloring is kind of ugly
and we're working on those things
hopefully that will be done by 12 2
right
we have a first prototype of vector
geographics almost finished
whether it will be in a an exposable
shape for 12 i'm not sure yet but it's
it's almost there
and in terms of our you know new map
themes we're also working on those yes
we are yes we have some basic style we
we are to start modifying and but
it in its that part needs considerable
work but i mean we're planning a plot
themes multiple plot themes for
different maps
yes and eventually this will be a bit
like uh
anatomy data in which you can specify
the styles individually for different
layers of things
because with the vector maps we can
distinguish the layers
yeah that's nice we should do that
that's good um
okay other car actually i noticed that
uh the
complaints about openstreetmap but i
noticed that steve costas was
was making some comments on this live
stream so we can
we can have um uh i don't think there's
anything wrong with the maps i think
it's just a question of
of um uh our um
uh you know our rendering of these
things which has been
was long delayed by the need to uh
expand our infrastructure for map
delivering map tiles which is now done
and so we should be ready to do these
things and to make use of other
things like geograph which i hope will
be able to get soon
which is things like the graph structure
of streets and so on
um okay some other comments on our live
stream here
uh they're questions about relativistic
effects
um uh
we are not ready for those basically for
all this stuff
i mean this is surface of the earth um
jose do you want to comment on this
there are two
parts here one is the relativistic
effects on time
and those will be added at the same time
that we add lip seconds and other time
systems
and when we can distinguish utc from
atomic time
from terrestrial time at the time we
will include the
time at the solar system by the center
and the time
at the surface of the earth and the time
of the center of the earth things like
that
but those are times where the
simultaneity surface where the bary
center
was synchronized by a light signal
in other words how does that how is that
synchronized to the earth
so these are just proportionality
factors so what they
they do is that they have measured very
precisely the gravitational differences
and then they have introduced some
constants
that accumulate in time i mean it's it's
just a a drift
in a linear drifting in time and so
that's just an optimistic yeah right
so the second thing i was going to
mention is that once we have
full astro functionality implementing
like
i'm moving at this speed how do i see
things
that's going to come later will be a bit
more difficult but
at in time will be will be simple
yeah i mean you know the fact is we
don't have
you know our frames you know we have the
notion of location
and time we do not have the notion of
reference frame
right i mean in general we could imagine
just like we have a geo location
and a and a time we could imagine a
reference frame as well
just like we can imagine you know datums
and things we have datums and things for
geo positions
exactly right i think that's the correct
way to think about it is that there's a
coordination
that is induced by the reference frame
that we're using to
and that reference frame might be going
with you know beta equals 0.9 or
something in which case we get
different results i think that's the
right way to parametrize it isn't it i
mean that's sort of the obvious way to
do it
right so so the future of astroposition
will have frames
inside as you say imitating the datum of
astroposition and then you will be able
to say
oh i'm referring to the center of the
solar system or the center of the earth
and will that also support things like
whether you're talking about celestial
coordinates like right ascension
declination as opposed to altitude and
azimuth or is that a different thing
that's different so that's not different
than datum
so they are related it's a bit like the
distinction between projections and
datums
it's here we have frames and coordinates
and coordinates
but the fact is that that in principle
you know if your
you know your friendly you know galactic
center black hole for example
in principle if we had the right data we
would correctly have
the um uh you know if we specify the
frame we will correctly have the
um you know time dilation and all those
kinds of things in there
the the um you know gravitational
redshift and everything
if i'm not mistaken in other words if
you could give the the
what would you give you give a metric
tensor basically is that right
well again i'm expecting that
the way to approach this will be by
having precomputed
factors because we know the the the
difference in gravitational field is
constant
between the center of the galaxy and
here
so we don't have to integrate the metric
every time we do a computation
i see i see your your point is that we
actually have to do essentially parallel
transport to get
from here you know to know the time
differences
the difference in the rate of time
between here in the center of galaxy
in principle we have to transport
something from here to there
is that what you're saying well it's a
it's an integration that gives you like
in the end it's
like a quotient of two integrated things
on the metric
but that quotient will be fixed because
if we are comparing the center of the
galaxy with the center of
of the earth i mean
yeah it's going to be the same so
rather than computing it every time we
will just pre-compute
the factors the same thing they they do
for the
difference in time between the center of
the earth and the center of the of the
solar system
it's it's a it's a fixed constant
proportionality factor
but it's not always that way right i
mean if we were if
you know in if we wanted to deal with i
don't know
two black holes binary black hole system
or something
with complicated i mean then it
certainly wouldn't be the case that
given any two points there
where how we define the coordinate
system for those two points that the
difference in phase would be some
constant i mean difference in um will be
some constant thing
that will be varying dynamically exactly
yeah in a very dynamical situation
or do you specify arbitrary points for
which you haven't
pre-computed the difference you have to
do it
okay that's a coming attraction
um let's see
oh boy the ethan is commenting on on
um uh if and when we have
i mean you know there have been like uh
satellites that have raspberry pi's
running well from language that are in
orbit and so on
and they've been they've been i know i'd
be interested to know how many
how many of our um
how many wolfram engines well from
kernel language kernels and things have
been
extraterrestrial so far but it's a
decent number over the years
um and their comments about
communication systems between
microsatellites using relativity
yeah that's complicated um
okay uh
steve is commenting that date time
object should be a synonym for date
object there's
some case for that i'm not sure i mean
we have an awful lot of date functions
what's that
i don't understand the comment oh this
the comment that a date object is really
a date time object
we haven't really been strict in the way
that the date framework works that a
date
only refers to year month and day or
whatever equivalent on whatever
calendar and the time is always a subset
of it but
i don't know that is certainly okay the
question that now being raised is what
happens to all of these time functions
of geolocation is on mars
what's that no go ahead i mean concepts
like solar time
and sidereal time are defined for the
planets so
there might be ideo model option in some
of these functions
is it easy to add i mean it's definitely
not worth a huge amount of effort to add
that what about for the moon
that's a mess right because
well it's it's a matter of knowing with
high precision the rotation
and yes the moon is a complicated system
yes because it's
its rotation is so tied to its orbit
right but for other planets should be
relatively easy
well what would we return i mean the
only thing we can return
is uh local solar time right
because nobody defined time zones for
the moon
right right exactly it would be local
and somehow we would have to
probably specify inside that this is
much uh machine time yeah but
what's the zero of martian time how does
it know when they
you know does it the sidereal time is
that to find
i don't know what is the first point of
areas or something
is that right i don't know when what
what is the zero of of
solar time the seed of solar time
is the is the position of the sun so
noon is when the sun
crosses your meridian so if you know
your longitude
then you know summertime i see
okay so we can define solar time for
these planets
yes as long as they have defined a well
a good notion of longitude which from
our studies it's the one we use in our
maps of mars well so is that for the
moon
i mean but the problem with the moon is
do we have any function that currently
gives us the rotational state of the
moon
no exactly we don't have that and
because it's not not constant
then it's complicated because for mars
we can assume it's rotating more or less
constantly like the earth itself but the
moon is very complicated
but so the the notion of i see the
the point is there is no notion of local
solar time
on the moon because the fact is you
would normally expect
you know a lunar day is 28 days you know
is equal to a lunar month roughly
give or take and so
you could say that local solar time on
the moon
is determined by a 28-day cycle but
that's probably pretty silly
and so okay so i don't think it makes a
lot of sense for the moon
and um we would get we might get errors
of 12 hours of things like that right
because they did
the rotation of the moon this 29.5
average can vary a lot yes
i i get it right so there's no
meaningful
mean solar time on the moon
well precisely the mean might if we use
the exact night 20
right but they may differ from the
apparent local
exactly solar time by a substantial
amount
exactly i think this is one of those
problems that we are not going to solve
i think we should generate an error
message if the geo position is on the
moon
um
let's see uh there's a question here
from brian is there a way to calculate
earthrise from a particular position on
the moon or mars
that's a good question how would we do
well because the moon is
basically face locked to earth for all
intents and purposes the earth never
rises from a fixed location on the moon
it'll stay in the same basic position
it'll wobble around a little bit
but there really isn't an earth rise the
sun will rise
but earth will be in a fixed position
from a position on that i mean the
you know the the the apollo 8 earthrise
or something was because the
you know the spacecraft was orbiting the
moon
right exactly
for mars and other things yes in theory
there is a concept of sunrise and sunset
times uh
well i mean that's basically just
looking for
the positions of stars from
a i mean we should get that almost for
free
when we have this whole astro position
stuff working correctly
because we'll know what in celestial
coordinates what the position of the
earth is
and then we just have to map that into
the local coordinates
you know altitude and azimuth on mars
don't we
or am i confused no no i i think you're
right
okay
okay ethan is talking about frame drag
oh my gosh that's too complicated for
now
um let's see if we can okay we got
through our first item
unless unless there's any other um is
there anything else to go over in the
first item here
no i don't think so okay that was very
useful
um
yeah swsh is pointing out
um um
uh i think we answered this about what
the zero of time on mars is it's when
the
it's when the sun midnight on mars
in in solar time is when the sun
is when you're at a location which is
furthest away from the sun
um okay there's a complaint here about
about um uh speed of pausing strings and
data object yes that is an issue what
nick what is the story with that
so the there's basically
the parsing part itself is generally not
the the slow part
it's the the setup and validation around
it we've talked about having a more
efficient way to
parse a lot of different date strings
because basically
we just need to we need to solve this
problem yeah we've looked at potentially
having
it be a solution in date array or to to
streamline
the process there the data i think we
just need to have no setup i mean i
don't know what we're doing
we're using some crazy library or
something to do this yeah i think we
need to just get it to work ourselves
okay yeah i mean there's still two
tracks of date parsing too there's date
parsing with a particular format and
there's the heuristic parsing which is
inherently a more complicated operation
but
well i think we should do it with a
specific format and i think we should
get that in raw
low-level code and we should do it as
soon as we can because it's a it's
definitely a bottleneck
right can we can we actually look at
that i really think we should solve this
and i don't think we should just solve
it for data raise i think we should
solve it for individual dates just
just nail it i mean it shouldn't have
any setup it should be a very
straightforward thing
it should just you know boom it should
just go through and do it
okay yeah we'll we'll bump that at the
priority list and please
take a look at that soon okay terrific
okay um this may be it for what we need
jeff for
um yeah thanks if um
no problem i'll drop out then so all
right thanks
so this is something that has been
requested by external users the
the ability of doing accumulate on
associations and
i'm not sure at the end i propose an
alternative
which i'm not sure is good enough using
subset map
wow okay so what's the issue with
accumulate on a on an association could
in principle
take the association in the order that
it's in
and take the values here and do the
accumulation
correct yeah and in some cases if all
the keys
and values are of the same type it makes
sense
my main problem with this is that then
differences which is kind of the inverse
will fail because we don't know which
key to remove
hold on by the way a comment from ethan
about timing complaints for importing
yes we are working on it csv import all
these other things we made them
dramatically faster there will be still
more speed ups
but it's a slightly different group here
okay so the issue with differences
why i mean for for a for a list
don't we know which one we're not we're
dropping i mean we're dropping the last
i see what you're saying the question is
what's the alignment of differences
here it's like partition if we were to
do partition
well a partition wouldn't eliminate
you partition by two you don't eliminate
any one but in differences it's not
clear whether you are
you eliminate the last i mean if i do
this
and i say you know does this work i
don't have no idea i can't imagine this
works because what's it gonna return
but not because exactly this doesn't
work because we don't know
which head to introduce
this is slightly different problem
right yeah the natural thing would be to
introduce another association but then
with
which keys
okay what is the use case for
accumulation on an association
so i think it has been suggested by
having associations with data for
example
copied data which is now used
much so if you have dates go to cases
per day you want to accumulate them why
isn't that a time series function
i mean that thing is a time series it
could be yes yes but
i guess this comes from people saying i
have an association i want to work
directly
but as i said subset map works nicely
with these so
perhaps that's the solution we should
i don't even understand what that's
doing what is subset map doing here
so it's extracting some elements doing
the accumulation on the list and then
reintroducing them
um how is it so okay so the point here
is i mean okay the basic point is
accumulate
isn't a problem but you would expect
differences to be the inverse of
accumulate
yes i find myself using both together
very frequently
and the issue is that unless you put a
zero
at the beginning with differences
there's a mismatch in the length
right right because
there is a unique i mean it's not a
one-to-one mapping
between uh accumulating differences
basically
in other words for a given accumulation
there are many differences which would
satisfy that accumulation
right it's like a constant of
integration so to speak for the
for you know accumulators integrate or
something accumulate which way around is
it
no accumulations integrate well i'm a
little bit confused about how this goes
but
but basically differences there is an
arbitrariness
you can add a constant to everything and
um
right yes i think it's very clear if you
if you write
differences of abc
and then do accumulate on that to see
the constant appearing
all right so you see you need now to add
a to everything but still
you don't get the a back you only get b
and c
is there a way in differences of giving
of specifying i mean
right now differences
i see step s apart but like
uh partition there's a question of where
does it start
oh it's right now differences can't give
you a thing that starts with zero
exactly yeah yeah exactly yes that's a
good point we'll have the offset
argument of partition
right but if we had that for differences
in other words differences there's an
identity between differences and
partition
probably should exist which right now
this is the same story differences step
us apart is that is that correct
actually is that the same as what would
happen
in partition or not i'm not sure i see
the relationship
it's not the same thing it's not the
same thing never mind wrong i'm wrong
okay but but there is an offset there
now if differences
were to put zero in the first argument
then we would be able to have
accumulation differences be
inverses of each other
and it's not obvious to me that we
shouldn't just make that happen for
differences in association
or is it too weird i mean differences in
association it's like
be happy it actually worked
and the fact that there's a zero at the
beginning just doesn't seem to me
you know obviously stupid
well this is a bit like what happens
with quantity stuff
which kind of zero do you need it's a
zero meters a zero real
zero integer
introducing a zero arbitrarily is
usually problematic
i think well but isn't that zero
whatever you get
by subtracting you know the first
element from the first element
that's what it is okay and if and i
don't know what i mean if i say
you know one point minus one point i'll
get zero point
yeah so so you're saying we can deduce
which zero would be
that's what i'm thinking yeah i think
differences i think you can define
differences perfectly well for an
association
you just have to have that zeroth first
element
um now what other functions go with this
and for example i i would claim that the
second differences and things is also
definable perfectly well definable
it just has to start off with it just
has to you know
start with taking those minimal
you know zero differences and so on
um
okay so is that reasonable approach i
mean i think we should just do that
make accumulate and differences both
work for associations
any objections we should i i think i
need to think a bit more
the case of higher differences
introducing many zeros
it i'm not sure it's the correct thing i
wouldn't know where to put them at the
beginning and at the end
or at the beginning
what's that hello yeah that was really
weird
did you hear those very loud beeps nope
i heard them i heard them could have
been on jose's hand
okay so maybe
um okay uh
well think about it okay and that's my
my first cut and how to make that work
so in the echo front we were discussing
this function that would report
uh the expression before evaluation and
after evaluation
and uh so yeah so we have discussed this
echo before after
and um
yeah so here we were trying to see how
to nest them
and um and how they relate to these
function that holds the first argument
because
in order to report something different
before and after evaluation you have to
hold the argument indeed okay so what
does this do
so echo before after it might have a
prompt
you know
i go for after label okay
so those are pairs so one could argue
that what should happen is
that there should be some different
you know iconic prompt for the before
and afters
you know label followed by something
which is an indication of the fact that
it's the before and after
i mean i almost feel like it's some kind
of bracketing construct that's needed
to indicate the before and the after
and it's almost like i don't think this
is necessarily right but it's almost
like
the first one needs that and the second
one needs of this
i don't think that's quite right but
something like that
i think this is an interesting construct
um its name is a little bit long and
ponderous
i go across
um echo evaluation
that's not bad yeah does nothing work
okay various people are pointing out
ethan says the function exists in
general utilities
and tally says yes he wrote that as it
says echo held
and brian is suggesting echoes true i
don't even understand that is that is
that like an old english
we met strew i don't i don't understand
that word
what is that word is that a word
always keen to learn something new
i don't think that's a word well at
least we don't think it's a word
why is this take so my gosh
ha well
not in my whatever it is 45 000 known
words
i guess something you say something is
strewn about perhaps
yeah yeah you say it's true but it's
true i've never heard it and it's in its
non-past participle form
okay in any case
echo evaluation seems not completely
silly what does echo held
do right now the general utilities echo
held
echo hold and it prints the same things
but with an arrow between them instead
of on two separate lines
and there's some clickability
what do you mean clickability what does
that how does it what what does it allow
you to click on
let me see again i'm not super familiar
with it
okay
um listen i just want to comment a
general point here about wfr
and so on i mean one of the things that
we should start doing over the next
little while
is you know we've got you know well over
a thousand functions in wfr
and you know it's it's time to start
looking at some of them
and considering you know what do we need
to do to promote them to system
functions
and you know we're about to hopefully
have an initiative in the next couple of
months
to uh you know add a lot of other
functions covering um a lot of
algorithmic functionality and so on to
wfr
um so i mean we need some process and i
don't know
i think this meeting is going to be the
right one to do it in
where we're looking at wfr functions and
considering them for promotion so to
speak
do we have an idea who's going to look
at them and how that's going to work
and how we should do that
um perhaps the reviewers of the
submissions have suggestions of which
ones they found
particularly interesting yes anyway i
think we're going to need some meeting
to kick off that process
um okay prepared
yes so this was we had discussed this
other function paired
yes and there
he this was a discussion of whether we
can get
via paired the same behavior of echo
evaluation no way as i agree the whole
thing is going to get too complicated i
mean this is a convenience function
that's easy to write
uh and i don't think that's realistic to
have it
be combined but okay so let's look at
um can somebody how do i how do i get
this
okay so now what am i saying it's echo
echo hold
and one plus one yep
okay and what does the pinkery do
youch what is that
i'm assuming this was useful for some
debugging purposes
but i'm not sure
it's cool but
look i think in the case where
okay imagine it was echo evaluation
and then what comes back that's
definitely not the right symbol to use
there that
is a function symbol which i have to say
i think is underused and i really like
it when i use it in code
it really looks nice um you know
the um
[Music]
clearly not this
it's really nice um
okay so echo evaluation
then the idea would be it simply echoes
once before once after and the only
question is what are the prompts look
what do the default prompts look like
right right
and and we agree we need two different
lines because things might happen in
between
oh definitely yeah there's no way this
is going to work
and and also these things could get long
and we've got you know we've got all the
apparatus
to deal with you know things that what
is that
oh well well it's a it's a early version
of click to copy i suppose
um
makes one think that there should be an
argument to echo that allows one to give
a wrapper
but i think that's overly elaborate okay
so echo evaluation so the question is
what do the what is the iconography of
the default
um what's the default iconography
for this um right now we have
for general echo
we use that kind of thing
and for echo with a label
same
that's kind of weird spacing
i'm a little confused by that why is
this a little space there
and why does the label come after the
prompt
why isn't the label before the prompt i
mean before the before the
uh that thing
anybody know um it has always been like
that
i think i think the prompt helps
identifying
things in a long output fair enough
okay i mean i think the spacing is
slightly wrong here i think there needs
to be a little bit more space there
but i find myself using
lots of labels and i usually put
semicolon space in the label itself
so it's yeah it's not clear whether
we should let users decide whether
a label a space is needed
is this 12-2 no
shall i run 12-2 yeah i think you've
commented on this before and we did add
a space
after the label i see okay fine
especially because in the terminal there
was no space at all between the label oh
that was hopeless
okay all right but so the main question
here for echo evaluation is simply the
iconography
which you're saying it needs to be
iconography independent of the label
because the label might be added
anywhere i mean the label
could be we're going to assume that it's
the same label
uh going in and coming out so to speak
there's a separate issue of having a
label
you know a label on the way in a label
on the way out so to speak
right right
um okay so that looks better
it looks fine okay so okay iconography
guys
what should we be using i mean
anything with brackets is going to be
weird with
we could reverse the game for the first
echo
and leave the second one the same
i think that's gonna look super weird i
mean you mean
like so it looks like this yep
so the first line would be like less
than less than
one plus one and then eventually greater
than greater than
two
i mean that was my thought up here
it's not absolutely abominable the
second thing that gets echoed is
identical to yeah yeah which is kind of
nice
because it would be the it is the
correct generic
echo
swsh on our live stream is suggesting a
tutorial about these things called
debugging acoustics
which will be misunderstood is something
about our audio functionality but also
uh thank goodness we don't have by
default things where
people you know like the very first
computer i used
very long very very long time ago had a
tone generator
connected to it so you could actually
hear
it's the execution of a program in some
sense
it was amusing that's about all that can
be said for it
i can imagine all kinds of tones
generated for these things
um all right look i think this is a good
good place to start let's try this
all right okay and um
echo evaluation would be the thing
and this sounds like it's another the
whole discussion what is this
this is a function we were designing
probably the main section is uh
so that's the code you can evaluate that
section and then look at the
the comments in there so that that's
called
the important details and the next one
um oh sorry i it's it's
my my private uh
okay um yes so so this is the this is
the syntax so this is a function we
wanted to
to use to
add coordinates to
data so like positions
and be flexible with dates and your
positions etc
and so how is it adding them
so perhaps if you look at the examples
it would be clear
okay so touch coordinates abc
yeah this is useful piece of
functionality
definitely a useful piece of
functionality
yes yeah this was just
to continue the discussion of the syntax
and how many possibilities
you can go to evaluation and choose
local which is i forgot to
to change my my kernel yeah
and yeah they are local
or default yeah i guess default
i'm not sure it will work to do that i
think it may be on a cell by cell basis
that this has been set
no i think i think it should work now
try to evaluate the code section
oh you're right so now you're getting
above the difference
okay
um yeah so this should work on
quantities
uh the oppositions dates everything
and there's a third argument to specify
which type of structure you want back
like pairs of of things or rules
association document yeah
second argument it looks like right no i
i see i see this
the second argument here is a bounds
argument
exactly that specifies the coordinates
you want to add
as opposed to a data range object a data
range option to do that
right you could add dates there exactly
no but i mean a data range would be
saying
i see the main point of this is you've
gotten back
a raw collection of values
but i mean this is kind of the inverse
of values like you take a time series
and you say values and it just gives you
the naked values
without associating their corresponding
times
exactly right and this is the inverse of
that
right so this is useful for example to
say oh i got a
quantity array of elevations back and
then now i want to attach the proper
coordinates
right
well it's useful functionality for sure
um
but by coordinates what we mean is
the thing will scan over take the second
argument as
bounds as coordinate bounds basically
and then it will kind of
uh assign those by default it will take
those coordinate bounds from the first
argument if it's obvious what they are
like part numbers but if not it will
take it from the second argument it will
equally space
things in those um in
a series of levels right so if you just
give a pair of arguments there
it will at the top level of the first
argument it will equally space things
between those things like a range
exactly
so in the second argument we specify at
which level we are working
by specifying two ranges we know we are
working at the second level
so it will introduce coordinates
homogeneously at the second level of the
first array yeah i get it
i i don't really like the name attach
coordinates i think it's i think the
functionality is good
um
what the heck are we going to call it we
had some other possible names here
prepend is bad
is it coordinates we want to call it or
is it range
what is the the functions that say
things like coordinate bounds
are they
um
what's that why did it do that
um i'm confused by that
because it's considering you are giving
a single point in 10 dimensions
so so try something like random real
um one and then ten comma two
so that's ten points in two dimensions
and i will give two ranges
okay whereas this will give the
corresponding
that will just give the transpose of the
other one
right if you had said 10
3 i think it would be clear
right now why do we think that the
coordinate attachment thing doesn't want
both of those cases in other words what
you feed it in
is essentially either a bounds or a
bounding box
if i'm not mistaken yes i'm just
following the idea that we
in general we use more bounds than
bounding boxes
fair enough because for example imagine
that different dimensions
have different units because we have
three parts of mass
right right so it's more natural to put
together the
masses and
um
um
well okay so so the question i i get it
okay so this is more bounds thing
but the question is what should we call
it
um
if we continue with the idea of
coordinates i liked
coordination because it's a single word
but you find it sounds a bit technical
it sounds like we're doing generality
i've been i've been explaining too much
listen i i've just
i've been trying to figure out how to
coordinate meta mathematics
um it's actually a very interesting
problem
the in other words you imagine the space
what's that i didn't understand what you
mean well so imagine the space of all
possible mathematical statements
right i want to coordinate that space
the the space of possible mathematical
statements they are connected
by deductions right there you you can
get one statement from another
at least if you assume certain axioms
but now the question is how do you
coordinate eyes
you've got all these things you've got
this big network of what follows from
what
but what if you want to actually give
coordinates what if you want to have a
coordinate system that describes you
know
you go from one statement to another and
i think the tentative belief is that
model theory
is essentially the coordination of
metamathematics
um okay the preview of actually we to
talk about this tomorrow but a preview
of um
um i think we are figuring out what the
analog of the einstein equations is
in essentially meta mathematical space
and um where where basically
the analog of gd6 is shortest proofs
i see so in other words the the concept
isn't and i think
that the the analog of that causal and
variance stuff
is essentially the univalence axioms
um anyway it's it's a uh
it's a it's an emerging discussion but
um
um this is quite irrelevant i'm sorry it
just happens to what i'm thinking about
it's it's kind of the
okay the the preview point and i should
we should wrap this up and the preview
point is is really that
that the question is
in physics there's all this complicated
stuff that happens
but we as computationally bounded
observers
sample only certain aspects of what's
happening in the physical world
and by virtue of what we sample we
conclude things like general relativity
or quantum mechanics
are features of the world even though
the low-level machine code of the world
is something very complicated but those
features are still identifiable to us
and similarly in mathematics what i
think is the case is that the
the underlying all possible mathematics
is a horrible
messy computationally irreducible thing
but my current speculation is
that the core axioms that are used in
human mathematics
basically are slicing off aspects of
sort of meta mathematics
that are much more much more ruley much
less unruly
than the general case and that that's a
um
a consequence of essentially what in set
theory is the
extensionality axiom or what becomes the
univalence axiom which is essentially
the axiom that says
things that can be proved equivalent can
be considered identical
which is kind of a coarse graining
statement about metamathematics
anyway this is irrelevant to the current
discussion i don't know why
i i have no no credible excuse for
bringing this up
except for the fact that that i'm i'm um
i'm all excited about the
the analog of of general relativity in
um
uh in um in mathematics does that make
any sense or was this too short of
description
absolutely incomprehensible
well if you can introduce a metric of
this a notion of distance between
elements of the theory then i mean i've
heard of such things in statistics and
other face spaces in which you can
define a metric and then
right but the point here is that i think
um
you know there is a way in which sort of
one statement is deducible from another
so that gives you you know and that's
what our theorem prover does
right in fact the thing that is just
absolutely outrageous as it turns out
in our theorem prover in the in the
proof networks
we have solid lines we have dotted lines
and it looks strongly as if
the solid lines are sort of um
the analog of evolution parts and the
dotted lines are the analog causal edges
and even more bizarrely it seems like we
can define an energy function
in our um in sort of the the meta
mathematical proof space
um anyway this is um
we're going to talk about it tomorrow i
think um
the um
um
um
yeah people are commenting on um um
uh on these comments that i'm making
come tomorrow we're gonna discuss meta
mathematics and physics tomorrow
afternoon
um which i'm looking forward to and i
really think
it's it's really a quite wonderful piece
of unification between physics and
mathematics and the most bizarre feature
of it
is it it reveals
that mathematics is a more human
activity than physics
which i think is really kind of
interesting that it's more
there's you know there's more kind of um
empiricism to mathematics than there is
to physics in some sense
i claim anyway this is irrelevant we
should we should wrap this meeting up
before we go
too deeply off into into the the depths
of
um uh
of matamata okay i got to tell you so
you might ask what is the analog of mass
in metal mathematics okay
and the the speculation is that the
analog of mass is abstraction
and that what you're talking about is
the paths of of geodesics that
correspond to proofs
around and the the issue is sort of how
much abstraction
is there in a particular kind of area of
meta mathematics
and that that somehow is what determines
the um
the geometric structure so to speak of
this space of possible uh mathematical
statements
so if that works then i i've been long
on the path of trying to
essentially um quantify abstraction
and this would actually give away to do
it which would be really exciting
um and and then and then there are all
kinds of fun things like the analog of
black holes and so on and the event
horizons is all quite fun
um anyway coming attraction sorry uh
um sounds very interesting yeah i guess
this is an infinite dimensional space i
mean it must be
oh very much so yes and and very unruly
and and not
yeah it's it's a very you know more like
our brand shield space in quantum
mechanics
um and i mean the the the thing this is
actually a
jonathan idea that um the causal
invariance the analog causal variance
which is corresponds to this univalent
foundations thing
is uh is sort of just like in quantum
mechanics where
the causal variance implies the
existence of objective reality
even despite the many branches of
quantum mechanics
that same thing would imply the
existence of objective reality in
mathematics
um which is an interesting claim uh that
is the
the um uh the analog yeah anyway
too many things to talk about by the way
yesterday we were talking about higher
order corrections to einstein's
equations
and and the possibility of viscosity and
space time
um and and it looks like again this is
irrelevant and i really shouldn't be
um but it looks like the um uh the next
order corrections
are of the order of the elementary
length divided by
like for example we can look at the
attenuation of gravitational waves
and well it's essentially the the the
characteristic length of
of a curvature change divided by the
elementary length
appears to be the um uh
or rather the elementary length divided
by the characteristic length
of a curvature change appears to be the
analog
of the knudsen number which would then
give the
the um you know the order of magnitude
of corrections
to the einstein equations which
unfortunately is very tiny i mean
that that number is absurdly tiny it
implies for example
that the attenuation length for
gravitational waves of the frequency
detected by ligo is 10 to the 84
universe radii which is
quite big but the thing that is sort of
strange there is this question actually
i
could ask you i'm sorry because it's all
irrelevant and i apologize for for the
um
uh um in um
well there's there's questions about
what the analog of dissipation
is in in our models and what it is and
i mean in in relativity
the structure of the theory on a large
scale well
there's a question of how energy
conservation should be thought of as
working in you know if you have a
rapidly varying metric
does energy conservation how does energy
conservation work
well the fundamental idea in general
activities that one
doesn't have a notion of local energy
you cannot assign
energy to a finite region the only thing
you can do is assign
energy to the whole space time and
therefore the idea is that energy is
being radiated
towards scribe and then at scry
you can say taking into account the
energy that has been radiated this is
the sort of dissipation
the energy is conserved so the energy
that remains inside
plus the energy that has reached
infinity that's the constant
but you have to always ask about the
total energy
the difficult thing in generativity is
assigning where the energy is
right fair enough i mean that's that's
not
that's not inconsistent with what i
think is going on in these hierarchies
um okay somebody's asking on a live
stream
am i a platonist you know i am about to
have
a really quantitative way to discuss
that question
i think um and and so it becomes it will
become something that
trans transitions from being
philosophical to being
uh you know pragmatic and computable
with
um and uh anyway all right i i think
it's um it's time for us to wrap up here
we clearly need this name
the functionality is looking really
interesting for attach coordinates i
think coordinators and i
that caused me to go off on a ridiculous
tangent here
um uh
i think coordinator is a little weird
and technical sounding
um
i don't know what we should do there
exactly okay needs a name
all right we should wrap up for now um
uh
great i look forward to talking to you
all soon and thank you to folks on the
live stream
good and interesting comments um and
maybe i'll see some of you tomorrow in
the
discussion about metamathematics okay
talk to you all soon